folks we're back i'm here with norm
mcdonald
now norm uh you know you're doing
weekend update again this year
you got to do a lot of stuff about the
news that's all you got to do is the
news that's it what are we going to be
hearing this year
well i'm looking forward to the olympics
coming up you know that's my because i i
love sports you know
i watch every sport so the olympics is
my favorite thing and
uh i don't watch them like sometimes in
the olympics they have like
like lame sports you know or they're not
real sports you know like uh
a lot of times what they'll do is
they'll try to combine
two sports together you know make up a
new sport right they're fine sports
together but when they mix them up they
make a
you know god-awful mess and like i saw
this one i remember
it was a guy he like run a 100-yard dash
and then uh fish you know the guy's
fish yeah so that's not a good one you
don't like that no
and then you know all the sports and you
know you know they got the
great sports and then the the bizarre
like you ever said one where they uh
they like walk fast it's the fastest
walking
it's just a guy walking fast and uh
and uh you know like uh that the you
know this guy
isn't that doesn't get a lot of respect
around the olympic village you know from
like the
sprinters and stuff you know going hey
fred uh good uh
good stroll today there man that was a
that was a briskest uh
stroll i what do you smash the 20-minute
mile i heard
they said it could never be done
but it's weird is that guy gets a gold
medal
uh-huh and meanwhile like the decathlon
champ
he gets a gold medal you know that's not
fair like that they shouldn't get the
same thing
you get the gold medal you're ten you're
the world's greatest athlete you do ten
then the other guy walks fast
like crazy he should have another medal
yeah they should all right
he should get like they should give that
guy like a stick or something you got a
stick
you know a nice stick but a snake nice
stick that's for you buddy
[Laughter]
and then you can do all your great
endorsement deals there afterwards
all right well okay we know about snl
you got any other deals going you must
have something else cooking another iron
in the fire
i finished a book i just finished a book
that's going to be pretty funny and it's
really funny it's got great pictures in
it
yeah it's hilarious i got it here it's
uh here it is
it's howard stern's miss america
good boy there it is so you can go buy
that
congratulations on that that's terrific
that's a great book good for you
yep all right can you hang on one sec
norm because this is the part of the
show okay i wanted to just uh
quickly uh can i plug a gig yeah sure
okay rascals uh next week
in uh new jersey okay and governor's in
long island uh jackie the joke man
martin will be there oh that'll be a
good show
check go watch that